hello everyone and yes it is me again
with another game from the feeder
candidates tournament 2022 it's hikar
nakamura with uh the white pieces
against him or a job of the games are
incredibly wild and you guys will enjoy
this one if you enjoyed the previous two
you will enjoy this one as well uh
players are just playing incredible
chess there are no quick draws there you
know everyone is here to fight and
that's uh really really really uh
awesome uh so let's dive straight into
it there is quite a lot to enjoy uh
nakamura has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 we have e5 uh knight to f3
knight to c6 and the bishop to b5 going
for the roy lopez and rajabo of course
goes for knight to f6 the berlin defense
because uh like in hikaru's game who
whoever lost a game playing the berlin
defense so the three with the ship to c5
and now he car doesn't go for the
standard c3 or bishop captures on c6 he
goes for the incredibly rare knight b to
d2 and okay knight to d4 by rachael now
threatening uh to pick up the bishop
here but basically offering a trade of
knights he called trades we have
captures captures and now pawn to c3
chases away the bishop bishop to b6 and
now pawn to d4 yeah we have pawn to c6
now attacking the bishop and now moving
the bishop back with the allow black to
immediately go for this d5 thrust so we
don't want to allow that the captures on
e5 is better and basically it's the only
move that anyone ever plays in this
position so c captures on b5 e captures
on f6 and queen captures on f6 already
threatening checkmates on f2 uh kikaro
castles and uh a job of castles here
yeah and now uh queen to h5 it's like uh
it's like yanipong she is playing with
the white pieces uh but uh
you know uh he he might as well be
because here hikaru is actually
following the game and nipple played
against levon uh
in 2020 that nipple won uh but also
nakamura had this position against uh
aryan in a classical game in croatia in
2019 in the grand chester that was
played in zagreb uh where knight to f3
was played by hikar that game ended in a
draw but here hikaru says all right nepo
knows how to play nice uh you know
barbaric uh chess uh let's just do what
nepo does so he car plays knight today a
queen to h5 and now queen to c6 uh we
have uh rook to e1 in the game nipple
versus our knights to f3 was played but
here we have rook to e1 by hikaru this
is what he prepared and now it is uh as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game
so how do you tackle this well there are
uh quite
quite a few uh tries here you could play
d6 you could also play f5 f5 is very
very interesting if he captures we're
going to play d6 uh now um go after the
f5 pawn and
you know the game continues it's a very
uh dynamic way to treat this position
with black but in the game we have rook
to e8 by arajabov and now knight to f3
we have pawn to d5 striking in the
center uh it also means um
giving up this pawn but uh rajab wants
to
get some development in so e captures on
d5 rook captures on e1 with czech knight
captures and now queen to c4 we have
pawn to h3 creating a little bit of
breeding room for the king and bishop to
d7 now we have queen to f3 and
rook to e8 activating the rook we have
bishop to e3 offering a trade of bishops
and rajab of trade we have bishop
capture spawn captures uh and now rook
to e5 going after the d5 pawn and uh
while you could adjust the defender with
rook to d1 he carved uh plays a pawn to
d6 which is basically giving up upon uh
but uh it also allows him to open up the
position a little bit and create some
chances so queen to d5 offering a queen
trade but also just going after the d6
pawn and now he carries defends it to
rook to d1 uh rajava traits here we have
knight uh queen captures knight captures
and the rook captures an e3 giving back
the pawn but
keeping the pass pawn on d6 so rook to
d5 by hikaru uh preparing rook to c5 to
c7 to put pressure on the on the seventh
rank and now pawn to f6 we have rook the
c5 and rook
at the e6 here going after the pawn rook
the c7 now trading the e the d-pawn for
the b-pawn and of course we have a trade
rook captures rook captures and pawn to
a6 now and the position is uh
very much playable for both sides the
material is equal it's a bishop against
the knight and hikaru plays knight to d4
but the knight and d4 can never be
challenged that there is no c pawn or e
pawn to challenge the knight and also
the knight is on a dark square so the
light square bishop can't challenge it
uh this knight uh can remain on d4 for
as long as it pleases or rather for as
long as he carol pleases and that is
very annoying when you play against such
such a powerful knight so here we have
h5 better job of uh ponte h4 and now g5
uh trading off some material on the king
side pawn to g3 and the king to f7 we
have king to f2 both players just
improving the position of their kings
you have to activate them king g6 king
to e3 and now rook to d5
we have rook to a7 he goes after the
pawn here now uh we have a repetition
rook to d6 and pawn to b3 we have bishop
to e6
uh and here rook to c7 hikaru taking
away some very very important squares
from rajabov's pieces and here it's not
easy to find a move for a java for
basically what you want to do is just
waste them with something like bishop to
d7 or bishop to g4 or bishop to h3 uh
you know not uh not spoil your position
or anything keep the rook on d6 but uh
rajavo played rook to d5 which is a bit
more active uh square for the rook but
it allows hikaru to infiltrate the sixth
rank uh he doesn't mind this which is
very very interesting so hikaru goes for
rook to c6 now comes rookie five check
king to f2 not king d3 to allow bishop
to f5 check so king back to f2 and now
bishop to d7 and of course rook captures
an a6 here hikaru grabs a pawn g
captures g captures and rook to e4 going
after the h4 pawn uh we have rook to d6
now attacking the bishop and the bishop
the c8 uh we have rooked the d8 going
after the bishop now bishop to g4
rook to d5 again putting pressure on the
b5 pawn and just bishop back to c8
and it's a it's a very very tricky
position uh can you can you ever capture
the pawn on b5 uh and allow rook
captures uh
on h4 it would be it would be uh well it
would be dangerous so hikaru first
awaits he plays rook to c5 again goes
after the bishop bishop d7 rook the c7
bishop to e8 and now he plays knight to
f3 he defends his age for pawn
but now we have rook to e6 rook to a7
and now rook back to e4 we have rook to
a8 going after the bishop if the if the
rook moves of course and the king to f7
just adding a defender to the bishop we
have rook to d8 and now rook to e7 so it
seems like
even though you're up upon it's not very
easy to
make some sort of a push here the bishop
here just beautifully defends the pawn
so here rook to d2 and now rook to e4
again putting pressure on the pawn if
the knight ever moves we broke back to
d5 attacking the h5 pawn
and now king g6 simply defending it and
now we have pawn to a3 rook the c5 is
also a good try for hikaru just
preparing c4
but he wants to wait with that he plays
a3 now he has a very very flexible setup
so you can uh you know push c4 you can
push a4 you can push b4 if needed so
rook back to e7 and now knight to d4 the
knight returns to the immortal d4 square
rook the e for now putting pressure on
the pawn and here hikaru goes for it he
plays knight captures on b5 and this is
a beautiful position as uh you could
play it uh uh you know you could play it
incredibly well or you could play it
well and here
i believe rajabov played it well not
incredibly well here he played rook
captures on h4 a much trickier move is
rook to f4 check but it's a move you
don't uh
if you don't know it actually exists you
you i guess don't see it the point is
that now uh what do you play uh what
move do you do with the king if king to
g3 you're gonna play rook to g4 with
check and after king to h3 you're gonna
play bishop c6 attack the rook and the
knight so if the rook ever moves from
the fifth rank you're gonna win the
knight and if the rook wants to stay
here to defend the knight you're gonna
have to remain on the fifth rank but
you're gonna have to move away from the
d file and now bishop d7 we threaten all
sorts of nasty discoveries here once the
king moves now we capture it with check
and after king g2 rook to g4 check
ensures a perpetual for a job of because
you have to go back to the h file and
then we repeat
uh checking the the white king if you
move the king to f3 then the pass pawn
starts marching forward and now it's
hikaru who's in trouble so here rook to
f4 a slight improvement to rook captures
on h4 immediately but uh you know a very
important one so rook captures an h4 and
now knights the d4 by hikaru we have
rook to h2 with check king to g3 now
rook to d2 and now hikaru starts pushing
pawn to c4 rook the d3 with check we
have kink to h4 and now bishop to f7
attacking the rook here hikaru moves the
rook and now rook back to d1 uh hikaru
continues pushing pawn to a4 now rook to
h1 with check king g3 and h4 with check
here king to g2 attacks the rook and now
rook the c1 uh here uh the last good
attempt for for uh uh would be rook to
b1
but it's incredibly difficult to
understand why as uh max uh so nicely
pointed out on twitter does anyone
understand the nakamura
end game uh i i i really don't think so
so here we have
rook to c1 uh and now hikar starts
pushing pawn to a5 with king the h5 now
king to f2 king to g4 and now rook to f8
going after the bishop and this is
basically where the magic happens
what do you play here
if you move the bishop let's say bishop
to g6 then the problem is we can just
attack the bishop
if you defend the bishop we can push a6
if you play rook to a1 we push c5 and it
doesn't matter if you capture the a6
pawn or not
but you don't have a better move we're
just going to push c6 and after rook to
a7 guarding the square now pawn to b4
again is the winning plan uh even if
bishop to e4 putting um
some pressure on the position just b5
and if pawn to h3 we're going to play
knight to e to threaten this check to
win the bishop if the bishop moves here
then knight deceive a knight to f4 check
wins the bishop so you don't have a move
if you play king h4 we just play rook to
h8 to check king to g4 and now pawn to
b6 again uh completely winning uh rook
to a4 we're gonna play c7 and next move
plays pawn to c8 uh just win the game
you don't have any discoveries here uh
oh sorry not discoveries but you don't
have any uh moves here that that
actually work if you put the rook behind
the pawn we still promote and win the
rook so everything is completely winning
here for hikaru uh so
bishop the g6 or removing the bishop
anywhere isn't really a good plan so
here uh rajabov tried h3 uh he wants to
sacrifice the bishop in order to play h2
and h1 queen because the rook already
covers the h1 square and now there is
only one winning move for hikaru so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for hikaru while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredibly difficult move to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is rook captures on f7 yes
it seems like that's the first thing you
thought of but then you thought okay
it's probably not that because why would
there be a positive video moment but
it's actually uh really really important
that you calculate uh all the way as
there are many tricks in the position so
here rajava played pawn to h2 and also
congratulations to everyone who spotted
this it was not an easy move to make
ponte h2 now comes rook to g7 with check
and this is the problem if you go to h5
then we play rook to h7 and we pick up
the pawn so we don't have the past pawn
anymore and if king to f4 that was
played in the game now comes knight to
e2 with check
that's the problem king to e5 and now of
course not going after the rook
but rather knight the g3 that's the way
to win this as now you are covering the
h1 square and there is no uh move here
for uh for a java if you bring a queen
into the game we just captured knight
captures and after rook captures an h1
just a6 this is completely winning uh a1
we're gonna play pawn to a7 the pawn is
defended and
it's three to one of course completely
winning for white uh so after knight the
g3 rook the c2 check was played by rajab
of king to f3 now comes rook to c3 check
king to g2 and now rook captures on b3
but he car response are it are too fast
to be stopped now pawn to a6 rook a3
pawn to a7 and now king to d4 we have
knights to f5 with check
king captures on c4 and rook to b7
cutting the king off from the b file and
next we're just going to play knight to
d6 or knight a7 put the knight on c8 to
defend our pass pawn then play rook b8
and promote the pawn that's the plan uh
very simple one but an unstoppable one
so king to c5 now we play knight to e7
and he was in this position on move 75
that uh temurajaba resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
and hikaru bounces back in the
tournament after losing uh the
first game to fabiano carwana now wins
the second one against taymor rajabov so
really really an incredible comeback uh
the problem is after you deliver one
check we're gonna put the king on h1 and
there is no move for black here to make
uh okay you could make a move and you
could or it could be also be a very
interesting end game let's say pawn to
f5 knights the c8 now preparing rook to
be rook to b8 and the queening of the
pawn let's say f4 rook to b8 f3 for upon
8 queen uh now pawn to f2 hoping for
queen captures an a2 but there is queen
to f3 guarding the f1 square and now
rook to a1 with check king to h2 and now
f1 queen black also gets a queen into
the game and now of course you can't
trade if you trade even though you're up
material you're uh you're up a full
piece uh this is a known uh
this is a known draw of course uh
rook and the knight against the rook is
a draw except some very very special
positions uh but here you just have a
very nice force to check made in seven
queen e3 check you're gonna go king to
c6 and now you just bring the king back
down queen e6 checking to c5 queen to d6
king c4 and now the uh very well known
shark mating pattern with the queen and
the rook rook to be for chuck king c3
queen to d for check king to c2 rook to
the teacher king c1 and queen to d2 will
be checkmate so of course uh both rajabo
and hikaru know this and after knight to
c7 uh rejabu resigned and a very nice
victory for hikaru who bounces right
back with the white pieces in round two
of defeated candidates tournament 2022.
uh incredible turn of events uh hope you
guys are enjoying it uh
as much as i i'm enjoying uh making
these as uh is just you know uh the
candidates uh
don't always have the the most exciting
games but here absolutely every game is
exciting in uh
in a way and the the positions are so
complicated that the players just don't
have enough time to you know uh work
everything out that happens in the in
the end game
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh we are uh uh we
already covered three games from round
two we might cover the fourth one we'll
see how it goes uh i would like to wish
a very happy birthday to levon and i
would like to thank andrew lastova uh
johan derek king and aravind kumar
vandelli for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day sorry about
so many videos
in one day
see you soon